un mur qui tombe à donc le 9 novembre
1989 sa construction commencer le 13
août 1961
philippe rochot retrace maintenant
l'histoire de ce symbole appelé aussi
mur de la honte
la jeunesse de berlin s'attaquant au mur
de la honte
ils étaient des milliers ce soir du 9
novembre 89 à la porte de brandebourg
fraternisant entre allemands de l'ouest
et allemands de l'est
c'était la fête des retrouvailles après
une séparation de 28 années le monde a
gardé cette image de la chute du mur de
berlin
mais c'est oublier que le rideau de fer
entre l'est et l'ouest avait commencé de
se déchirer deux mois auparavant le 10
septembre la hongrie a décidé de laisser
passer sans permission spéciale les
allemands de l'est
voulant se rendre en autriche toute une
jeunesse en vacances chez les frères
socialistes hongrois en a profité ainsi
pour passer à l'ouest
la tchécoslovaquie de son côté a laissé
des milliers d'allemands de l'est se
réfugier à l'ambassade d'allemagne
fédérale
d'où ils ont gagné l'europe de l'ouest
la brèche s'est ainsi ouverte
quand la république démocratique
allemande fait le 40e anniversaire de sa
création
des milliers de jeunes citoyens est
allemands sont déjà passés à l'ouest
la leçon est dur pour le numéro 1 de
l'allemagne socialiste est riche en
équerre à côté de gorbatchev qui va lui
souffler l'histoire punit les
retardataires autrement dit les
soviétiques l'empêcheront pas
l'ouverture des frontières des pays de
l'est
le mur de berlin est condamné quand les
centaines de milliers d'allemands de
l'est en cette nuit du 9 novembre 89 se
sont rués vers les points de passage du
mur les trois cent mille soldats
soviétiques présent en allemagne de
l'est ne sont donc pas intervenu les
riches en équerre l'aurait pourtant
souhaitée car ils voulaient empêcher que
ne se brise ainsi ce que le régime
appelait le rempart anti fasciste
l'antifascisme était officiellement la
raison d'être du mur de berlin
comment c'est de bâtir en 61 afin de
protéger le socialisme de rda
en fait il s'agissait d'empêcher les
allemands de l'est de passer à l'ouest
239 personnes y ont trouvé la mort en
voulant traverser clandestinement le
dernier chris gay froid neuf mois avant
la chute du mur face à un régime
est-allemand affaibli corrompus grâce
aux coups de boutoir de l'opposition et
grâce à l'aide de leurs frères de
l'ouest
les allemands de l'est ont fait tomber
le mur de la honte mais c'est
l'allemagne fédérale qui va
littéralement digérer l'allemagne de
l'est
le chancelier ouest allemand helmut kohl
a clamé à l'est de leipzig à erfurt sait
à présent qu'il peut jouer la carte de
la réunification des deux allemagnes